We have manually written
our own request directly
to the wire and received
a response from the server
just as the server send it.
It feels raw, close
to the bare metal,
doesn't it, like there's
almost no software between us
and the bytes being sent.
And yet there's still
so much happening
that we can't directly
see, and it actually
has a big impact on how fast
the entire request response
process is.
If you are a little familiar
with networking architecture,
you might know that HTTP is
not the entire story, that's
merely the protocol.
For a more complete
picture, we are
using HDP on top of TCP on
top of IP on top of ethernet--
probably, mostly, maybe.
The point is we don't
need to understand
each of these layers,
but TCP in particular
has a big impact on
how we should structure
our requests to have
them perform well,
and it warrants a close look.
The internet protocol allows
us to talk to other machines
on the internet,
while TCP allows
us to have multiple,
independent streams of data
between these two machines.
These streams are
distinguished by port numbers.
The TCP protocol also ensures
that no packages get lost
and that they arrive
in the right order.
All of this requires precautions
that cost time and resources.
Opening a new connection
is especially costly,
as the TCP handshake, which
makes sure both machines are
aware of the newly created
communication channel,
has to be executed that
requires two round trips.
If you're using HTTPS, the
additional TLS handshake
has to be executed as well.
If HTTPS and TLS are new
to you, stick around,
and we'll talk about
them in the next lesson.
Once all that is done,
the actual HTTP protocol
can finally take over.
Head-of-line blocking
is a huge bottleneck
to website performance.
Browsers being able to open
up six parallel connections
helps, but it's not great.
Later we'll see how
HTTP2 fixes issues
with head-of-line blocking.